Mình có tâm chăm sóm vi sau từ án nhạm ở sau ở đăng được trên khai
với quy mô bài chăm sóm vi bài nhìn bài chăm bài me tạm cân
Tổ mức đầu tư khoảng sau trong lệ nắm nghiên tạm trong bệnh mối tì đầu
trong đó có hai chăm tảm vi chính giữ án thân thân thân
quy mô một chăm sóm vi bài nhìn hai chăm bệnh vi chính cân
hai chăm sóm vi mô tự án đã khởi công sây dức
đăng trên khai với quy mô hai chăm sóm nắm nghiên tạm cho mối sau cân
bài chăm mối sau giữ án được chăm thận chủ trường đầu tư
quy mô bài chăm lại nắm nghiên hai chăm bối bài cân
theo kia hoa đường bộ xây dức có mô hỗ đầy là cân sở để tiếp tục trên khai
mục tiêu khoảng thành một trong nắm nghiên tạm nghiên tạm
bài chăm cân nhà ở sau hội trong nắm hành hình thung trong thêm sau
có phần đáp ở nhu cầu nhà ở bảo đảm án xin sau hội
bộ xây dức cũng tập trông khoảng thiện chính chính phủ
thu tự trình phủ bán hành quy định mở gióc đối tượng推 nhà ở công vụ
tạm các địa phương thuộc viện sắp sẽ đến bị hành thình cấp tình
kể hoạt phát triển nhà ở công vụ của các cơ quan Trung ơn giá đoạn
từ hành hình thung trong thành sau đến hành hình thung trong bà mời
mộ đáp nụ tiêu vận hành trình hoa thông tin
giữ liệu trên hệ thông thông tin
có sử lếu về nhà ở và thiệt trường bất động sản
nằm bảo kết nối liên thông bởi cơ sở giữ liệu phô ra
có sở giữ liệu trên hành
các thông tin giữ liệu trên hệ thống lực cập nhật đầy đủ
chính sáp ký thời thường xuân liên tộc
tạo điều kiện trong người dân và dân nghiệp dễ dàng chắc ký thông tin
đông thời theo dõi sát giết biển thiệt trường bất động sản
ký thời nghiên cứu lệ sốt cà sải pháp ở lực tị trường
thảo gưỡa khó khăn cho dân nghiệp
thúc lời thiệt trường bất động sản phát triển
ăn toàn, lạnh mạnh và bên dân